et maintenant du monde entier
tu sais pas
tu espères
non
ici c'est bien j'appelle miss france
talus djamal t'embrasse 420 bonsoir vous
êtes la nouvelle miss france et vous
êtes une femme on vérifiera
contrairement à elodie gossuin
oui donc il n'est jamais bon pour une
couille qui n'est pas la connerie alors
vous a prévenu que vous allez prendre 10
kg dans les foires au jambon on vous a
expliqué ça va je vais tout le monde
étant donné qu'on doive retrait cir
toutes les robes noires
j'ai pas la fois la tradition elin
réveillée une qui veut pas venir
ouais les visas à temps 1 pierre
lellouche
c'est la bombe c'est quoi galabru ah
ouais qu'est-ce qu'ils fassent kate moss
qui sortait du ritz a été prise en
chasse par des paparazzis il a fallu
arrivé ce qui est arrivé à cette pauvre
lady di puis cette bagnole qui l'ont
poursuivi et tout ça a dit la fille elle
est pas mort tu n'en avais pas morte
mais enfin cieux alors le tunnel n'a
rien le tunnel variable de plantes au
numéro 13
ouais si elle veut venir raconter son
aventure dans tout le monde en parle la
bienvenue voilà il n'y a pas que toi qui
souffre des paparazzi un bon alors avec
sandra on vous a prévenu que vous allez
prendre 10 kg dans les foires au jambon
la wii mais ça va je serai tout
mouvement de l'état donné que je suis un
peu trop fines donc il faut refaire
toutes les robes pour moi jusqu'à
laurent pasquet bill evans mais bild
mais laurent itunes est tranquille
j'essaye de comprendre jusqu'à prendre
avec sandra oubliera vous savez qu'on
vous arrêtiez c'est d'être belle nous
c'est d'être con voilà
on nous a prévenus vous avez vous
engueuler avec madame de fontenay nous
coûter pour le moment ce passionné donc
on verra bien par la suite mais ça va on
nous a prévenus que vous risquez de
faire de la télé réalité de poser nue
dans playboy
ça je pense que ça n'est pas des miss et
moi je me sens ça va arriver
ah bon pourquoi parce que je ne vois pas
l'intérêt d'aller poser nue sur sur un
magazine la soignant mais bon avant
d'être ministre s est jeune il est très
bien donc je vois pas pourquoi j'aurais
besoin d'aller connu pour de l'argent il
faut travailler il ya plein d'autres
choses à faire
alors pourquoi vous avez gagné parce que
non sérieux vous n'êtes pas tellement de
poitrine en fait c'est pas du tout c'est
parce que c'était en maillot deux pièces
et les jambes qui vous attendait
justement si j'ai gagné c'est parce que
c'est pas un concours de beauté miss
france il ya un test de culture générale
il lui suffit pas d'être belle et tais
toi ils nous envient nous en vue pendant
un moment évolué suffit pas d'être
jeanne sinon plus le dernier soir est
tout à fait important est gentille deux
derniers soirs les jambes aussi quand
même ben je sais pas j'ai fait dix ans
de l'athlétisme sammarcelli jambes alors
on les voit pas trop me provenant jean
parce que je suis décontracté on vous a
dit de vous méfier
on ne nomme pas dit ou non c'est que
j'étais connu l animal l'honneur avec
des jeans vous rentrez pas aux
chandelles
pas grave j'avais pas y aller donc alors
le matin des élections vous étiez encore
châtain non j'ai jamais fait j'ai été
châtains clairs ou blancs français ça on
m'a juste fait quelques mèches bonne
mais j'ai jamais été faussée non plus
vous étiez jamais monté à paris non plus
mais alors s'il vous plaît ouais ça va
c'est différent du sud mais la vie
parisienne a fait pour rigoler le nickel
alex ne soyez pas pareil acte
aujourd'hui j'avais aujourd'hui vous
avez un bel appartement dans des
soutiens très bel appartement de
contente vous faites la cuisine vous
même j c mais bon il vaut mieux que je
commande et voilà si vous avez plus de
fiancé vous
nikos et a duré quand même un an et demi
non ouais vous êtes prête moi une grande
aventure aujourd'hui non pas du tout je
préfère profiter était en voie d'être
est coupée en fait donc le droit de
sortir par donc maintenant que quand que
je profitais des boîtes parisiennes je
préfère m'amuser c'est vrai ne cherchez
pas en aventure contrats export et le
grain d'amour ses 13 hommes de tami
mieux mais je vais pas aller un nom si
le grand amour et grands habillés en
noir avec les tempes grisonnantes nom va
se mettre au régime alors qu'on peut
appliquer dans le menu ce que vous
appeler alex c'est vrai l ex on se
connaît un peu pas beaucoup finalement à
tes amis au bar on va se réalité